il y a 16 ans, un abandon scolaire semble juste
suffisant pour un aller simple pour Paris
peut-être que je le voulais vraiment vraiment alors
quand je l'ai eu trop tôt et je m'y
accroche qu'est-ce que tu veux je vais diriger le
meilleur restaurant du  monde il est sûr
qu'il est célèbre si vous êtes un chef il est comme
les Rolling Stones Je ne veux pas que mon
restaurant soit un endroit où vous
venez manger pourquoi les gens ne s'assoient-ils pas à cette
table être malade de nostalgie alors où
vous avez  été la Louisiane
ne marchez pas glisser renifler injecter
si vous essayiez de commencer l'arrestation
il y avait au moins une douzaine de personnes
qui essaieraient de vous faire donner la cuisine
est le seul endroit où j'ai jamais eu l'impression que
j'appartenais vraiment
aimé chaque minute le  chauffer la
pression la violence que se passe-t-il s'il
réussit les feux d'artifice l'immortalité
que se passe-t-il si vous échouez
Adam Jones et Gordon on espérait que vous étiez
mort
maintenant je suis de retour vous regardez ça tout le
temps ouais quelques fois nous avons pris les
chemins oui ouais regarde de  c'est oui oui ton
travail oui